うわ、うわうわうわ.....
ちょっと待ってくださいよなんすかこれちょっと待ってくださいよ
ここになんかこういう周平LOVEとか書くってホントにやばい
うーわ...
なんか書いてある
なんすかなんスかなんスか!
こーーーーわ!
ここ通ってないのか
うーわ、うわうわうわうわうわ
ちょっと待ってくださいなんすかこれちょっと待ってくださいよ
まぢもんじゃないですか
うーわ!
うーわ。
ちょっとがちじゃないですかこれーがちじゃないですかちょっと...
がちだよがちw
とぅーーーす!
というわけで今日は,
先輩と、
ホラー心霊スポットを、
ぶっ潰しにきたんで
片っ端からね、
ゴーストたるゴーストをね、
なぎ倒しに行きたいと思います!?
いってらっしゃい
一人無理っすよ
ここなんでしったけ..
はなし?葉梨トンネルという、
場所で、結構静岡じゃ有名な
有名な、そう、なんか出るって言われてるトンネルなんで
まあパパっとね、行きたいと思います
いつ行くか!?
今でしょ!
というわけでやっと決心して入ることになりました。
うわ!
うわー。
失礼しまーす
怖い
え、え、なんすかなんすか
どおしたんすか
どうぶつ
だと思います
うわ、こーわ
なかって意外とあれですね、
濡れてないですね
どうすかこの、カメラ越しの、
ん？いいんじゃない？
いいですか？
水がしたたる.....
水が滴るいい男ですか？
うん
あほか
うわっなんかかいてある
葉梨
K F
卒
なんかの記念イベントですか
ここになんか周平LOVEとか書くってほんとにやばいですよね
あたまおかしいね
ここに書くってどうゆう
え、なんか
字が見えないんだよな
なんか書いてあるんですよね
『心霊上等』って書いてあったらしいよ
ふっ
心霊上等w
≪ED≫♪
なんすかなんすかなんすか
なんすかちょっと